Шановні семикласники, вітаю
вас на уроці української мови.
З вами я – Людмила Зленко!
Допомагати нам у цьому буде
відома тисячам телеглядачів панда По.
Що ж, традиційно починаємо з
перевірки домашнього завдання.
Повторимо. Я пропоную
вам декілька тверджень.
Ваше завдання – уважно
послухати їх і вирішити,
довіряєте ви цьому твердженню чи ні.
1. З -нн- пишуться прислівники,
утворені від прикметників з подвоєнням.
2. У прислівниках зрання, спросоння,
навмання, попідтинню, попідвіконюю
пишемо -н-.
3. -нн- пишемо у прислівниках,
утворених від прикметників
з наголошеними -анн-, -енн-, -янн-.
У вас є хвилинка, подумайте!
Перше запитання. Що ж, справді, з -нн-
пишемо такі прислівники,
які утворені від прикметників
з подвоєнням.
Друга відповідь - ні! У прислівниках:
зрання, спросоння, навмання,
попідтинню, попідвіконню
завжди пишемо -нн-.
Третє. Подвоєння справді відбувається у
прислівниках, утворених від прикметників
з наголошеними суфіксами
-анн-, -енн-, -янн-.
А. не підходить.
В. химерНо, схвильоваНо, легковажНо
– всі три прислівники
мають лише одну літеру -н-,
тому що утворені від прикметників,
де подвоєння не відбувається.
Друге.
А. закоННо, безбороННо, неодміННо
– саме цей варіант і є коректним.
Третє.
Пам’ятаємо, прислівники
зберігають правопис
тих частин мови, від
яких вони утворилися.
Відмінно – з двома літерами -нн-;
темно – з однією літерою -н-;
гуманно – подвоєння відбувається;
здивовано – подвоєння не відбувається;
спонтанно – подвоєння відбувається.
Що ж, я впевнена, ви були
уважними і маєте гарний результат
вашої домашньої роботи.
Переходимо до теми нашого уроку.
Сподіваюся, ви не забули, зібравши
печивко на відповідних слайдах
за правильно розв’язані завдання,
наприкінці можемо перевірити себе.
Що ж, переходимо до теми уроку.
По пропонує задуматись,
чому у прислівниках:
докупи і восени ми використаємо
прислівниковий суфікс -и-,
але – укупі і навесні напишемо з -і-?
Що ж впливає на вибір суфікса?
Розглянемо відповідні правила.
Із суфіксом -і- пишемо прислівники.
Наприклад, навеснІ.
Суфікс -и- ми використовуємо.
Наприклад, восени.
Наприклад, співати по-італійськи.
Наприклад, лежачи.
Повернімося і дамо
відповідь на питання По.
У слові докупи та восени
приголосні п та н є твердими,
використали прислівниковий
суфікс -и-. У прислівнику укупі - "п"
є пом’якшеним, тому
ми використали суфікс -і-.
У прислівнику навесні н є м’яким, тому
ми використали суфікс -і-. Будьте уважні!
Що ж, багато з вас можуть сказати, що
мультфільми – річ дитяча і нічому цікавому
та корисному вони нас не навчають. Однак
По пропонує п’ять своїх життєвих правил,
дотримуючись яких ви
обов’язково будете щасливі.
Давайте перевіримо і
спробуємо відредагувати,
можливо, знайшовши деякі помилки.
Перше.
1. Жити можна по-ведмедячі,
а вчиняти по людські.
Зверніть увагу на прислівники: чи
правильні суфікси ми використали?
2. З друзями вкупі легше долати труднощі.
Прислівник вкупі
– чи справді має бути суфікс -і-?
Третє.
3. Успіху не досягнеш лежачі.
Чи влаштовує нас таке
написання прислівника?
Четверте.
Допомагати треба залюбки чи залюбкі?
П’яте.
5. Вірити в себе віднини і назавжди.
Звучить досить дивно.
Давайте перевіримо!
Перше. Жити можна по-ведмедячИ.
Нагадую, прислівники, утворені
за допомогою префікса по-,
після -ч-, пишемо суфікс -и-.
Прислівник по-людськИ –
те саме правило: прислівник,
утворений за допомогою префікса по-, після
літери -к-, використовуємо суфікс -и-.
Друге. З друзями вкупі
легше долати труднощі.
ВкупІ: "п" у нас є пом’якшеним,
тому використовуємо суфікс -і-.
Третє. Успіху не досягнеш лежачИ.
ЛежачИ – це прислівник, який
походить від дієприслівника.
У таких після літери ч пишемо суфікс -и-.
Четверте. Допомагати треба завждИ залюбки.
Використовуємо суфікс -и- в прислівнику
завждИ, тому що звук "д" є твердим.
ЗалюбкИ
– використовуємо суфікс -и- після к.
П’яте. Вірити в себе
віднинІ і назавжди.
ВіднинІ – використовуємо
суфікс -і- після м’якого н.
НазавждИ – використовуємо
суфікс -и-, тому що звук "д" є твердим.
Наше завдання – зібрати
прислів’я з двох фрагментів.
Отже, давайте ознайомимось
із можливими варіантами.
Перша частина.
що маєш робити, без діла жить –,
хто спішить, лінивому,
грамоті вчиться–, хто нічого не робить.
Другі можливі варіанти.
все ніколи(и, і);
той нікол(и, і) не має часу;
завжд(и, і) пригодиться;
то зроби сьогодн(и, і);
тільк(и, і) небо коптить;
той двіч(и, і) робить
У вас є декілька хвилин
подумати і з’ясувати,
які ж прислів’я будуть правильними!
Перевіримо!
що маєш робити, то зроби сьогодн(и, і)
Прислівник сьогодні напишемо
із суфіксом -і-після м’якого н.
Друге.
без діла жить – тільк(и, і) небо коптить
Прислівник тільки напишемо
з прислівниковим суфіксом -и-
після твердого к.
Третє.
хто спішить, той двіч(и, і) робить
Прислівник двічі напишемо з прислівниковим
суфіксом -і- після пом’якшеного ч.
Четверте.
лінивому все ніколи (и, і)
Прислівник ніколи напишемо
із суфіксом -и-після твердого л.
П’яте.
грамоті вчиться – завжд(и, і) пригодиться
Завжди напишемо з -и-після твердого д.
Шосте.
хто нічого не робить,
той нікол(и, і) не має часу
Прислівник ніколи напишемо
з -и- після твердого л.
Що ж, друзі, давайте пригадаємо
синтаксичну роль прислівника у реченні.
Для цього визначимо головні і другорядні
члени речення у двох прислів’ях.
Спочатку пригадаємо.
Члени речення можуть бути
головними і другорядними.
До головних належать: підмет,
який відповідає на питання (хто? що?)
або присудок, який відповідає на питання
що робить? що з ним
діється? яким є наш підмет?
До другорядних членів речення належать:
означення, яке відповідає
на питання який? чий? котрий?;
обставина, яка відповідає на питання
де? як? коли? навіщо? звідки? і так далі;
додаток, який відповідає на всі відмінкові
питання, крім прямого називного.
Отже, переходимо до речень.
Записуємо наші два речення.
Пригадаємо, починаємо з
визначення граматичної основи.
Шукаємо підмет, тобто
виконавця якоїсь дії:
Хто нічого не робить,
той ніколи не має часу.
Підмет – хто, представлений займенником.
Яку ж дію він виконує? –
хто не робить – присудок.
Той ніколи не має часу…другий підмет – той
(ще один займенник) і присудок – не має.
Ми бачимо дві граматичні основи, а отже
пам’ятаємо, що наше речення є складним.
Рухаємось далі.
Не робить нічого…
Ставимо питання: не робить (що?)
– нічого. Питання що? – це додаток.
Не має часу…не має чого? – часу.
Чого? – питання додатка.
Не має ніколи (коли?) – питання обставини.
У нашому реченні прислівник ніколи виконує
для себе притаманну роль обставини.
Запишемо друге речення.
Починаємо традиційно
з граматичної основи.
Шукаємо підмет: Без діла
жить, тільки небо коптить.
На перший погляд, звичного
для нас підмета в реченні немає,
але пам'ятаємо, що підметом може
бути не лише іменник у називному відмінку,
але й, наприклад, дієслово в інфінітиві
(тобто, в своїй початковій формі).
Шукаємо: без діла жить…жить
(що робить?) – інфінітив,
який виконує у нашому
реченні роль підмета.
Шукаємо присудок: жить означає
що? – означає коптить.
Тобто, у другому реченні граматична
основа представлена двома інфінітивами:
жить і коптить. Саме це, до речі,
є умовою для появи цього тире.
Рухаємось далі. Жить без діла…
Жить (як?) – обставина.
Коптить (що?) небо – додаток.
Коптить небо (як? ) тільки – обставина.
В другому реченні прислівник тільки
виконує теж притаманну
для себе роль обставини.
Що ж, я впевнена, це завдання було
вам під силу. Тому, ловіть печивко.
Перевірмо.
Впевнена, ви впорались із цим
завданням. Тому, ловіть іще одне печивко!
Для наступного завдання нам з
вами потрібно пригадати правила
виконання вправ з ключем.
З ними ми з вами вже працювали.
У нас є прислівники, які ми
повинні написати із суфіксом
-и- або -і-, відповідно.
Якщо ми зробимо це правильно,
тоді, підкресливши у прислівниках
на -и- третю літеру від початку,
ми прочитаємо закінчення
виразу. Давайте спробуємо.
Використовуємо вже
опрацьовані нами правила.
Прислівник тричі – суфікс
-і- після пом’якшеного ч.
Прислівник поночі – суфікс
-і- після пом’якшеного ч.
По-заячи – суфікс -и-:
пам’ятаємо що в прислівниках,
які утворені з використанням префікса
по-, після ч пишемо суфікс -и-.
До речі – прислівниковий
суфікс -і- після пом’якшеного ч.
По-дівочи – префікс по-,
після ч, пишемо суфікс -и-.
Верхи – використовуємо
суфікс -и- після твердого х.
Удвічі – використовуємо
суфікс -і- після пом’якшеного ч.
Отутечки – після твердого к
використовуємо суфікс -и-.
Рухаємось далі!
По-геройськи – прислівник
утворений за допомогою префікса по-,
тому використовуємо суфікс -и-.
Навесні – після м’якого н
використовуємо суфікс -і-.
Вкупі – після пом’якшеного п
Трохи – після твердого х
використовуємо суфікс -и-.
Щоночі – після
пом’якшеного ч – суфікс -і-.
Останнє. По-молодецьки –
пам’ятаємо, прислівник утворений
за допомогою префікса по-,
тому використовуємо суфікс -и-.
Що ж, виконаємо другу частину нашого
завдання. Візьму маркер іншого кольору.
Нам потрібно у словах, які закінчуються на
-и- підкреслити третю від початку букву.
Спробуймо прочитати завершення вислову:
«Коли закінчуєш хорошу книгу,
здається, що прощаєшся з…. другом».
Перевіримо!
Справді! Якщо ви виконали це
завдання коректно, ми отримуємо вислів:
«Коли закінчуєш хорошу книгу,
здається, що прощаєшся з другом».
Якщо ви правильно виконали це
завдання, ловіть ще одне печивко.
Підсумуємо, які ж правила
ми з вами вивчили,
які допоможуть нам правильно
писати прислівники
– із суфіксом -і- або суфіксом -и-.
Ваше завдання – уважно прослухати
твердження і відповісти: так або ні!
Перше.
У прислівниках: утричі, уночі,
насторожі пишемо суфікс -і-?
Так! Звичайно,
після пом’якшених ч, ч, ж пишемо -і-.
Друге.
Якщо прислівник утворено від
дієприслівника, після ч пишемо суфікс -и-?
Так, це правда!
Третє.
Після твердих приголосних
пишемо суфікс -і-?
Ні! Ми пам’ятаємо,
після твердих приголосних
ми маємо використати
прислівниковий суфікс -и-.
Після г, к, х пишемо суфікс -и-.
Так, правда! Після цих літер
використовуємо прислівниковий суфікс -и-.
Сподіваюся, сьогодні ви були не менш
активними, ніж на попередніх уроках.
Тому, порахувавши свої печивка,
можете оцінити себе самостійно.
Якщо ви зібрали максимальну кількість – 7,
ви чудово працювали, так тримати і надалі!
Якщо у вас від 4 до 6, вам
потрібно продовжувати старатися
і працювати в такому ж темпі,
можливо, трішечки уважніше.
Якщо у вас від 1 до 3, не засмучуйтеся,
передивіться відеоурок ще раз.
Я впевнена, ваші
результати стануть кращими.
Переходимо до домашнього завдання.
Слухаємо уважно!
Нагадую, фразеологізми – це стійкі
словосполучення,
які допомагають зробити наше
мовлення більш яскравим та колоритним.
Перегляньмо запропоновані варіанти.
…вітер віє, і вдень і…, іти…,
дивитися…вниз, …й довіку, їздити…
Друга частина: навпомацки,
згори, верхи, звідки, віднині, вночі.
Як ви бачите, у другій колонці
представлені прислівники,
у яких використаний суфікс -и-
або -і-. Пам’ятайте, крім того,
що потрібно відновити наші
фразеологізми, потрібно пояснити,
чому саме такий суфікс використано.
Якщо вам складно розуміти
значення того чи іншого фразеологізму,
можете скористатися одним із
словників, наприклад, ось цим.
На сьогодні ми завершили. До нових
зустрічей на уроках української мови!